okay it's your boy sack of Emma a lot of
people fear that name you know a lot of
people but today I'm your friend and
we're gonna watch The Walking Dead a new
frontier Episode five finale
okay I got my magic juice right here
which I like to call my gaming juice as
well it's like my energy and that I
guess episode five today or tonight
today I think that's what it was called
but maybe somebody Gallo's I don't know
I'm not a writer okay I'm a gamer okay
and gamers follow one important role of
gaming's never charger obvi I'm dead
okay
no good watches we all know what
happened okay whatever this thing is
between us I want to give it a chance
yes Mike and I know the fact that David
is back in our lives now makes this
whole thing a little more complicated
that's right
do you feel the same way I'm in all the
way
oh my gosh really really no look what
he's done
who's the killer right I got you donäôt
very interesting conversation with your
friend Eleanor last night now I tell you
right she is no longer my friend we did
you put me in a no-win situation here
both of them deserved to die for their
crimes
however hobby I'll let you stab it's
choppy but okay what let Ava live
children wait
I said don't shoot Ava you know how
about you take David and the rest of
your people and just get the hell out
we're leaving all of us right now
what the [ __ ] dammit think that's never
done anything right it's Kate she's
coming for us
no k +8 okay I don't think she made it
and probably not bring it over now
she could to say missing her head okay I
think it's the word ended right
[Applause]
yes the Fluxus they walk on all over the
place
all right here okay good thank you okay
here we go
while we're still breathing obvi I'm
letting the bone speak to me oh my god I
think I can hear them they're saying
you're gonna lose oh my mierda so play
already
I must have inherited patience for MA oh
come on man
calm down say like the domina delay
hurry no rush to lose
snake eyes man oh [ __ ] yeah there's a
girl yeah God ah yeah we're so close
you're now my least favorite song have
yet hi he's the one who beat you
fine way to die I hate you both
okay Cass it's a baseball can't play
dominoes what exactly you grid that
again Harvey grass stuck here what I can
actually play baseball slugger
that's enough both of you it's not
poverty's fault he's a disgrace to the
game of dominoes I won at ten bucks you
owe me both of you
I know you're broke hobby you should sit
out the next game since we all know I'm
gonna win this second batch I'll shave
and surrender home kid yourself
you got lucky luck luck it was skill
pick up little brother if you can I'll
cover for Xavier oh is it your turn to
do that now I lost track poor helpless
hobby it might be sighs needle keep an
eye on him you don't want him snatching
an extra 20 for gas money holy [ __ ] down
dirt yeah
sure pop all right snatch the Tony okay
I do it snatch the 20 can I do that Oh
what's this
hey man I was reading that what what huh
what the [ __ ] is this none of your
business he has cancer
huh
really I'm old old people get cancer you
didn't need to know that's not for you
to decide oh my god cleanse you tell us
told us it's the right thing to do
it's my cancer I get to do whatever I
want you know now what difference does
it make how bad it's okay mijo
ask me how bad is it you won't have to
worry about paying me back that ten
bucks
okay [ __ ] christ [ __ ] Sorry mate x88
now you haven't told my mom and neither
will either of you you hear me
mouth shut ah whatever you want ah I
won't say a word
of course I have to be the one who tells
her am I the only one here with any
sense of responsibility you're gonna
need her help with this bah driving you
to the doctor getting prescription wait
what are your options
treatment stuff like that he's been
holding radiation all that expensive me
and great when do you start I turned it
down turn it down you don't get to turn
it down so much money and for what
another month another game of dominoes
to loose it's not worth it
Oh still playing ball I could have paid
for it it kind of if I work it's not
happening
save your money [ __ ] money I swear
guy you can afford it David but my bride
can't let's play another game you're a
[ __ ] coward
a selfish coward Bobby can you believe
this [ __ ]
David I get it
it's not fair but come on take it easy
are they gonna kiss or what both of you
you know I pray for daughters every
night your mother was pregnant with both
of you please God my daughter
anything but a son anything but another
me anything but another hot-headed idiot
with his heart in the right place
anything but another foolhardy handsome
gambler anything at all please papa
don't give up fight fight for our name
for our blood for our family please
fight til I but ah live it however you
want or as long as you want you're both
the same only thinking about yourselves
David gets second dick oh my god
actually I don't worry pas he'll come
around
you should have supported him what what
I'm on your side still I'm gonna be a
name carved in stone before you know it
javea that'll be me letters on a rock
that nobody wants to visit I know you
think you're strong enough to handle
that alone and so does your brother and
you're both wrong you have to take care
of each other you two are all I'll leave
behind like Dave and Mariana will be for
David a legacy Javier it's all anyone
leaves behind that and their bones and
here's close were others before it's too
late
crack that [ __ ] that's not too much to
ask now I gotta have ever happened PAH
never don't be like me javi you have to
keep fighting I still need to pay David
hah boy if you had just won the game we
wouldn't have had this problem so you're
blaming me for all this I'm depending on
you mijo we both are
I'm gonna [ __ ] his wife there so doesn't
matter
she's not dead though seppia okay [ __ ]
[Applause]
J
okay yeah okay should I eat something or
is it time to Oh
temple step left holy [ __ ] I forgot that
I still try to get me doors open all
right Q yeah it's always Q and then it's
always a whoa oh that's [ __ ] dress
[Applause]
yeah [ __ ] disgusting okay Kate Kate
Gabe where'd she go Oh shame on this guy
got treat Gabe David where's Kate she's
not here she must have gotten out if
something happened to her if you've
gotten her we're here because of you if
something happens to her that's on you I
didn't start this hobby you did yes I
can't bad shape okay
hey David wait
yes no thank you
let this guy die it is as it now what
the [ __ ]
okay little intermission cuz I got a
text like a little when I rush it
chase s so if anyone wants to know
what's going on
oh okay one sec I'm stunning I was down
here
and I'm talking a text so Bert catch
skillet burn okay fish to continue okay
okay
so hey David wait to think I kissed her
before she turned into a zombie that
Kate I can't tell
oh thank god
so buddy thank god you're all right kiss
her kiss her I'm just glad you're still
in one piece
you're alive I thought I'd lost you back
there
save KITT KITT
what the hell's the matter with you to
focus on your surroundings
there's gaben Club lead the way hobby
later I have a as I'm talking about oh
[ __ ] I missed that one
hobby the first one I [ __ ] miss I got
a great teacher
you guys alright yeah I'm fine
yeah this place ain't looking too good
there's so many will be safer inside get
in here five one two you know what that
means that's the building number that's
the address yeah beer is like so good
for you can sing crazy that should hold
them for now you put up a good fight out
there I don't care what you think
da da da do not take that tone with me
you murdered that man after they let you
go you're a killer just like they said
you did that you don't understand it was
them or us he's a killer I did do it
they would never let us go they still
would have killed us sooner or later
they were negotiating with the Stephen
doing that to Clint was it necessary
that's how you see it I would do it
again [ __ ] psycho burying splattered
all over you for my son I am doing what
any parent would do to keep you safe you
do not get to judge my actions do you
hear me hey you do not walk away from me
when someone's good you stand up and
answer them cut it out David you don't
need to show how big and bad and tough
you are
to a fourteen-year-old boy he needs to
be taught you know firsthand aren't you
I'm just I'm trying to protect you Gabe
I lost you once I won't let it happen
again
yeah there I go okay we made it through
alive let's just be glad about that we
need to check the other entrances make
sure we're safe yeah want to help me out
not really but okay
okey Gabrielle
just be careful buddy lot I'm worried
those out there Dave and I will watch
each other's back okay I'll help too
okay house come that is a new one now
she can be [ __ ] at 28 no nose hey
cleanse with that it's fine it's not
that it's less just what give birth here
I'm all over the place I need to focus
on something anything just need to focus
on whatever let's just go upstairs the
further we are from these doors a
happier I'll be
I just want to get as much distance
between us and then where it goes as I
can yeah yeah okay let's go
good [ __ ] oh my god this is a [ __ ]
nightmare
there was that best she looks like a
[ __ ] doll man here I'm glad Mariana
didn't live to see this may tell when
her father's to come just be what I've
done she'd be just like that little boy
scared that the monsters are coming
after her neck
they should Jeremy I trust us again I
wouldn't blame her
hey come on we're not monsters
I don't know who we are anymore oh but
it's not the people she knew she knew a
reefer smoker I did this to them that
hole is there because of me I'm just as
responsible forward as you are you
weren't behind the wheel javi it's
different
they threw a [ __ ] mall top so I make
this right
all of this let's fix this as best we
can all right King
let's make things right I don't know if
it's actually possible but I feel a lot
better knowing you're there - Oh baby
let's go and ask you what they need I
guess you know anyway a towel Oh from
the swallows I got it okay oh these
people so we just [ __ ] it into their
house oh this [ __ ] [ __ ] you've got a
lot of nerve showing up here after the
[ __ ] you pulled
you're unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable today oh oh I've got a lot
of nerve everything that happened is
because of you this is all your fault I
told you I wanted you out of my life
after what you did to Conrad yeah why
did you tell Joan what we were do
I was triaging a bad situation there's
doctor is dead before you guys [ __ ] it
up their walls worked to think that I
want you to Sam I think I can actually
save lives here
not just stitch them up and hope for the
best
these people will die without me javi I
know she well [ __ ] us over but she's
trying to help him she's trying to make
something right Kate I can't even listen
to what they're saying they're so hot
she's trying that counts Eleanor is one
of us maybe she forgot it but I haven't
thank you javi uh it's shopping but okay
we should try to help not everyone here
is guilty I'm the one the cash gently be
a little girl out there she was right
behind me
yeah she died I'm sorry I haven't seen
any little girl
except yo you're a long girl already
crying
she knew Rufus he was her husband until
you shot him in back Hey one of my
people Eleanor what's going on with her
she'll be all right she's not bitten or
anything she lost her daughter out there
poor woman
she's so economically irresponsible it's
the least we can do I want to help you
okay well because of you hey little girl
killed greaseless was fine until your
stupid ass Jota
we're dead [ __ ] meet David might as
well take out this [ __ ] while I can
fern shut up you're wrong this wasn't my
fault but it was my baby
stand down if David that an order
okay no this is all because of me I
caused the explosion I killed your
daughter
don't you dare touch her forgive me
she's gonna get shot my fault
please I am begging you I hardly have
any family left please don't take any
more away from me yeah I bet oh it's
job' but that's insane really dinner
right even oh my god unacceptable
did you really need to break her arm
that wasn't necessary okay we'll make me
come
uh-huh no baby okay
I'm sorry that was an accident you were
going to kill her she was going for her
go get her escape she can't even stand
up what the hell is wrong with you you
get over to my gate you're right David
the bad dude I'm sorry I didn't mean to
do that to you that was thought out
everyone scared everyone why the hell
are you all looking at me that way
they're just they're scared baby of what
I'm protecting them why are you pointing
a gun at us
so I'm all alone yes
might as well suck on the chamber and
kill yourself five minutes
you people are on your own you people
that are racial slur just like you get
so don't try to project I've seen that
look in his eyes before you should go
after him like that [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah that's insane ass
a lot of beautiful women in this game
glad I paid off on that in this game I
love an ikat them again okay David what
are you doing huh thinking it over isn't
gonna do you any favors if you want a
jump just jump come over here
or are you afraid of me - I know the
rest of the market right I won't lie to
you man you have been acting pretty
scary so you are afraid you brought it
on yourself David [ __ ] nutjob my wife
Bobby my son and that job a better get
it me differently yeah it [ __ ] that
job maybe you're seeing them differently
I want to show you something stand with
me no [ __ ] dad enough man come on you
gonna pull me off the cliff
oh wow quite a bit out there just stand
down man hey he's gonna jab as I push
him yeah
I didn't expect you to understand I want
to change hobby I always have Eddie I
like we never tried to do was get me to
change only because I couldn't bring
myself to do it first
it's the one war I could never win and
I'm wondering why is it because I don't
know how or because it's impossible to
change who you really are
they're talking deck
[Music]
there's a way there always is
you gotta how lost you are you gotta get
help man you gotta get to random do you
find it looks pretty messy for now maybe
you're right maybe just got to live long
enough to find out just like with
anything else I promise they're up here
be careful
javi I ran into teller he was still
outside when we kept on the entrances
the Martos were everywhere
we got him inside just in time all right
so we let him in there was so many
weirdos out there that was the right
thing to do
proud of you buddy ready to go get
butt-ass trip how about it yeah about
that thank you - punching teeth though I
got every right really sure could you
put up a little bit of a fight oh
nothing more but I just can't shake this
slippery feeling I got what's he gonna
do I'm standing in shoes that don't
quite fit you picked me to die and
someone else did instead ain't sitting
right not one bit
I knew she wouldn't shoot you I knew she
was gonna shoot Ava instead that's a lie
[ __ ] her partner that's a horrible
lie with myself in your position about
Conrad about all this asking myself over
and over again whether I'd do the same
I'll have to tell you I wouldn't I
really would but I can't if someone
threatened my family I'd shoot him in a
heartbeat hell I'd shoot him twice to
make sure the lesson stuck
it's complicated world but at least
there's people to share it with bygones
how about it I mean if you are you bet
bygones I try not to piss me off again
please I honestly have no idea
this guy that came out of nowhere he's
not really my friend but he's just like
so forgiving it's even worse than you
think the streets are overrun nowhere to
go except inside the buildings and those
smelly [ __ ] are beating down every
door we're sitting goddamn ducks here
everyone in town is that supply but ok
what the [ __ ] are we done right now what
do we do I don't want to die up here
none of us do Gabe we watch out for
ourselves we're top priority absolutely
the best way to protect ourselves is to
protect this place essentially but with
the streets compromised we're gonna need
some sort of reinforcement mobility to
get around that armored truck you guys
stole there's more vehicles like that in
the same place that's over by the motor
pool with the water tower we could use
the highway overpass to get to the water
tower
come on let's jump
I think all right come on it's an easy
jump okay so how's he getting back keep
your eyes open
stay aware of your surroundings all of
you let's move out
hey David Munar you broke that craving
mothers are hug why do you think she
hugged you Kayla she loves me just
wondering that can only mean one thing
she likes me more not a great time to
joke around ami
that's choppy but all right
oh is that guy we got him guns and
careful needles the exact same thing
will happen to us stay sharp and do not
fire your guns we're going to be fine
that guy was all alone we're not what I
would do is I would just like goes far
rooftop watch they can fire put some
bolts in the air and then go back to my
original place after they're all drawn
away you know that's yes ma'am
everyone hold back but javi and I clear
out these walkers great thanks for just
inviting me good to go let's move
yeah
okay but
well I see you like not liking me I was
little had used to ask me what I wanted
to be when I was a man and pointed him
still ways like that not he was such a
great guy yeah lots of kids hero-worship
like that
it's part of the job yeah I guess it was
the only thing I hate more like a have
to save it let's bring on a shape
drifting in a while never be like your
honor
I told me that all the time don't be a
man who relies on other people to solve
your problems
what a [ __ ] person you're not a man at
all [ __ ] I think he was right not
anymore though hobby I can only help my
girl to be like you uh-uh
that's Javy but thank you so here's
hoping
oh thanks boy I mean a lot sorry I never
really said it before she should have
it's crazy because I've treated him like
complete [ __ ] the entire game like the
entire game now we need to take care of
dad he's the one who needs our help
I just got a lost cause but I had
we're gonna have to go around the side
there's barely any room
no time to waste
come on you know I didn't think there
was much I could scare me anymore yet
this thing Falls obviously so mad oh
here is the coffee of emotions and wakes
you up keeps you sharp
give me your friend if you let it I just
thinking on to fall off and Kelly take
my hand man
sure why are you like so nice to make
thanks drew that was aa [ __ ] you [ __ ]
stick some of a goddamn ya can't give
voice not it this ain't nothing once
we're back on the ground that's when
this shit's really gonna get scary I've
got a bad feeling good lord
it's nasty down there you just saved my
life thanks trip I'm glad you have my
back lucky catch that's all
Trevor what happened to Jay say what are
we do
yes to where that doesn't work we have
to get across
what are they trying to get across is
looking to airplane what the [ __ ]
I know Gabe doesn't see it but David
really is trying to look out for him
he's not doing the best job but no one
gives you a rulebook to raise a kid
Clementine here so Irish it don't just
one thing I don't get though what David
really think he was helping AJ by
letting him go why did he stop guarding
him maybe you should ask him that it
might be that he just didn't care
not everyone's like you caught not
everyone wants to take care of a baby I
guess not
but after you put in all that work how
much of your heart AJ was a brat
what he lived with me after we kicked
you out Clem had already raised two kids
got to be a piece of cake how was that
tyrant and now weren't you a plane made
a bad winter destroyed every cop we had
I couldn't leave Richmond and AJ
couldn't stay in Richmond
I gave AJ to lingard and told him to do
whatever he had to to save his life
I missed that Brett you [ __ ] [ __ ]
never hassling guard about it again you
should have tried harder there's always
a way he was your responsibility you
don't get to abandon that don't think it
doesn't haunt me
it wasn't easy Clem remember far as I
knew I'd already lost two children
wasn't any easier with number three it's
never easy I'm gonna keep you alive keep
all of us alive and hope that that's
enough enough for atonement Dave you're
actually like the worst your
responsibility no matter what I thought
it was best you thought wrong yeah maybe
I did
David you just full fuck-ups like no
wonder Gabe is so [ __ ] out like
honestly like Wow
holy [ __ ]
chopped right in half the language in
this game the language in this game
anything else I can grab how happened
here well there's the water tower not
too far away
okay go I have no other choice but to
grab that thing what is this oh there's
the other half no wait we're jumping
across that alright I guess you got to
do it
alright Charlottesville
oh [ __ ] this is a horrible idea
you're not thinking it's that or go back
we should go lightest to heaviest that
way it won't break on the first swing
I'll go first climb Wow
[ __ ] a that one first get a long
run-up but not too long if you take too
many quick steps you'll propel yourself
upward instead of out same with your
jump just run off the end don't behave
even try not to you've got this she's
right I do David go suck a dick on the
back somewhere okay I make yourself
useful
go lubricant some foreskin okay
are you swing this back my mom let your
turn another record I do not trust this
thing not at all
it's one thing for the kids to swing
across what I you've got this I've seen
you do things that are way scarier
all right let's see it I can do it
stripper socks I make it did I feel bad
trip is like a shet all right David
you're up little brother Iowa if she go
through David well you're definitely
lighter ah come on you know the drill
age before beauty [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm smaller than so I should be
safe I'm going last brother trip you
don't have just go before I throw you
across hey you can't have my guys it's
hang on javi
let's Johnny let's have eat them just
water
we just water been dipping ran Oh side
and I are the controls what is this guy
that's disgusting
you [ __ ] trip it's all right y'all [ __ ]
we should go back for oh don't be
[ __ ] sick I can't I can handle this
trip don't give up oh my god he'll
figure this out y'all head out now I
don't want to see in this all right well
you went out fighting
chef I kind of like Shep I hope I do too
he was a good guy I'm sorry about your
friends hobby you seem like a good guy
that's like a dick there it kind of guy
you want on your side the fight
come on we're almost there push it
[ __ ] call yeah a second cult Chet
okay
okay really mommy let Tony and Joanie
loved chachi he and I'm gangin dong ding
ding GaN dong is getting it it's like
they either have black hair gray hair
there's no blonde haired zombies from a
safe distance we need to get down there
we're not getting anywhere without one
of those vehicles one easily we could
just ask all those walkers to move out
of the way like what I just throw the
baseball bat like far away there we go
yeah we could use that generator that's
a great idea game when'd you get so
smart game when I was away from you you
really aren't the same kid I remember
well what can I say taught him well oh
my god javi really it's okay dad he's
right
and it's Javy dad not hopping okay
how to Walker open and cover yourself
with its guts and you can slip right
through them I climb you're [ __ ] nuts
what well I please tell me you're
kidding
now I like I said please so who's gonna
do it David
javi I've been willing to do some crazy
stuff for me before I know shooting
Conrad wasn't easy but it showed me I
can always depend on there uh you just
like [ __ ] volunteering me look it
smells really bad like way worse than
you think
thank you
you'll do
[Applause]
that's so gross close our eyes kits I
don't want you to see daddy coming man
you could do this Javier I got a proceed
all night [ __ ] Oh God Oh
I think you just literally eat [ __ ] all
day long
that why you smell so bad okay I better
be enough
that's not enough bro
shut and watch the [ __ ] [ __ ] here
is what this is the checkpoint
[Music]
there's this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
abort okay there we go
okay I'm there yeah what's giving a
[ __ ] stink eye
come on
[Applause]
[ __ ] so like Oh all people in local area
are going to go over at but isn't also
going to get the rest of the city this
way - you did it Harvey
barely let the [ __ ] to have it that
[ __ ] guy let's find something
reinforced like you said David something
to help us move around safely we're
saving the city before we do anything
else I'm gonna find something to seal
the breach with all we need is the right
vehicle
that's not gonna do the job man yes it
is
what are you doing the right thing I'm
leaving we're all leaving what and going
where you saw it yourself we're
surrounded by the heard I'm taking my
family out of here you helped keep them
safe Clem you're coming too
what you're just taking a get everyone
we can't wait around this is [ __ ]
David absolutely not
everyone in Richmond will die without us
they don't matter Bobby don't you get
that
this all started the day we knocked on
Richmond's doors we brought this on
these people all of us we can't abandon
them not after what we've done
we're going home Katie back to the last
place we were a family we're starting
over
we're all together again finally it's
time all of us a new day a new life what
am i here man make Richmond our new home
Richmond is gone
Bobby I'm not gonna let the people I
love die trying to save a dead dream
I'll go with you dad
what the [ __ ] he's my father Clem I'm
sorry but you really wouldn't understand
think this over buddy eight is this what
you really want I know it's scary out
there but I have to you don't have to be
afraid game I won't let what happened to
money on a happen to you all right you
have my word I will protect you the
right way don't you dare say her name
your men killed her which means you
killed her honey just stop
this is what I want huh I understand you
alright I'm taking Kate I'm still going
back I won't be able to live with myself
if I don't try to help the people in
Richmond you won't be able to live at
all if you do that Richmond is
compromised it doesn't matter if there
were five of us trying to save it or
five hundred we'd all die I know a
losing battle when I see one
we're moving out everybody get in that's
an order
how [ __ ] dare you what will it take
David what will it take to show you that
you do not get to do that we are not
your soldiers run away home be a
deserter I am done with you good good
let's go hobby why the [ __ ] do you think
he would go with you kisum Oh
tell him what the [ __ ] is this you
weren't a good husband to her David
she deserves better that's me oh I
should have known the night Paula died
the night you weren't there
blood is worthless for you just like he
was to you just like I am to you
okay raper save to finally learn the
blood really means hey Dad what do you
have to say for yourself
brother stop it I love you
oh no no you don't get to say that Jesus
Christ
stop what the [ __ ]
how [ __ ] dare you no stop it
demon stop oh my god I love you alright
stop saying that let's go we're on the
Gator out No holy [ __ ] you're not taking
my family for me baby
yo I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you I love you
brother
oh sorry I know
oh shut a
David is such a piece of chef
damn and we're any father struck you
with a rent should I do
David what the hell is he doing
yeah I just [ __ ] left David took him
we can't wait any longer
we have to go help Richmond what I'm
getting on that bulldozer but Katie
wanted to go he did we all heard it
you're you're right
damn stretches right my favorite track
she's my asking you let's split up hobby
I'll go after Gabe on that motorcycle if
you don't otherwise I'll go with Kate on
the bulldozer are you sure you'll be
okay without me I can take care of
myself
we're out of time javi I'm sorry
mmm I've been here before more than once
it's not gonna end well for everyone you
have to decide oh it's hard to be caught
in the middle I know that I can't like
hate go by yourself it's too dangerous
I'm going with Kate to save the city
okay then I'll go after Gabe it's a
smart idea be careful out there Quinn
you too both of you man well it's
tripper here if we're gonna drive into
the herd we're going to need these
holy [ __ ] just gonna be [ __ ] nuts or
knocking [ __ ] i don't you right now
holy [ __ ] there's just like you out
there okay here - happy site can you
help us get the gate open
holy [ __ ] is that Jason once I got in
contact with my people I headed right
back and to make sure you folks were
safe
I think I'm getting the hang of it we'll
keep the word goes away just get me to
the gate so I can open it up pressing
Kerala I'll be getting the bucket now
let's go to the top of the cage let's
get the thing in the side saying
whatever kitty we shed
all right
yuck papi
the buskin right yeah
all right so Javy let's do this
I'll have it open in a second they
couldn't just have an open gate button
what the [ __ ]
you did it hobby
bingo let's get inside and regular
waters together if we get them in one
group we can lead them right out
Nha say way back to where - stay away
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
full steam ahead
chopping you killing everybody you know
I literally count everybody that's that
one bullet one cow you know
Thank You babies [ __ ]
you're piling up on the sink the basket
[ __ ] I'm empty
here take over
let's put the grapes with the dance-pop
that's a nice patch
here we go
holy [ __ ] can I dump actually do that
there's cross
perfect that's it let's get out of here
oh we like Ryan I guess your tater oh we
shall world up these walkers Adam torch
the cake welcome back I thought we were
coming back to what well not to dit it's
just a little surprising that's all yeah
we've had some difficulties certainly
one way to put it
hobbie look it's Clem Gabe so what
happened to day he no no he's fine he's
just banged up what's happened clean
their car got overrun with walkers and
crashed I was barely able to save Gabe
what about David David's dead Terrence
we can finally be together cave in time
thank you thank you for saving Gabe I
don't know what I'd do if I lost him too
uh when I got there it looked like David
had turned and that Gabe had to stop him
Oh God
Gabe
it's horrible re blank but I can't be
shopping but what my dad yeah I know
buddy he's gone no no he wanted me to
tell you guess I guess up just care of
each other
Oh where did you find them a little ways
outside of town not too far no take the
car keep somewhere safe yeah sure come
on hobby where are we going a funeral
hmm that's my girl okay that's my girl
Kate okay
that's how I got K ah Shay's s
and I look like David and he's [ __ ]
drives room just way
[ __ ] this guy was at the same
that one alright yeah my cue hot port
degree by David look jacket I can't
imagine
Gabe's come a long way he's really grown
did he really need to learn this lesson
no Matt he talked about that every day
what to do when he died yes disgusting
she was convinced it would happen in the
field every day I'm surprising he was a
soldier I used to hate talking about it
but it seemed it to him she'd talk about
his military funeral the way that other
people talk about retirement plans
he'd only changed the subject if I
promised I'd bury these he didn't care
about burying his body as far as he was
concerned this was him help me dig it
doesn't have to be much start on the
sewer
barely in the crowd just like all the
ground they're gonna say something huh
what you do usually when you see pas you
tell them I said hi and then I'm sorry
for not paying you back there ten bucks
there do you you want to say something
yeah
so st. shut oh yeah bang yeah bye-bye
let's go
hey what I wanted this oh that's sweet
that's so sweet divorce talk make the
really shut Dan is either
this must be like the town still the
most of cleanup Richmond look at
Almighty recipe is forever an arch be
strong yeah let's do it look like holy
[ __ ]
oh they're also like drawings how they
keep that thing so flats with like not a
single crinkle there it was his own
fault
yep if you regret helping me if you're
feeling any guilt yep
bury it I mean it you're right he dug
his own grave
about it absolutely come on Spencer more
quiet girl
usually the client pairs me what about
now there's a lot of work to be done the
herd could come back still though I feel
more calm here than and I ever did in an
old van on streets with no streetlights
we are in this hobby
we earned feeling calm in the quiet huh
I got the good ending I guess I mean
disable you and me oh hell yeah baby
what do you think you're on let's start
a family you don't think it's selfish
it's not the safest world outside of
Richmond hello I did truth be told so
long as I got you I'm not too worried
about it
Kim at bay bay ah
we'll be up there before we know it
better do something worthwhile in the
meantime like her
set the inning
how can like a town forgive them like
they did everything
how's Jay say head no yes indeed we came
here to put an end to the rating looks
like that's been done glad we got it
settled got a move on we could use you
around here
please stay we got other people
dependent on us Tommy just weigh it in I
was worried about you havi
about who you are inside you helped save
these people though that goes a long way
for me second chances are in short
supply these days that's what this place
can be if you let it
trust me though life within walls is a
hell of a lot different than life on the
road don't take shortcuts like Joan you
got to do the right thing always good
days and especially bad absolutely the
right thing no matter what good to hear
I read people pretty well no gift of
mine your capable guy Harvey change is
in the air here you can lead that change
and I think you should for the better
god knows this town could use it you
know what I'm gonna step up lead this
place in the right direction as far as
I'm concerned
Richmond's in much better hands and it
was that's enough a'that Scott [ __ ]
Abbott oh Jesus
Kenyatta hey uh Gabe thanks for you know
not letting me get killed and for coming
back to help us yeah thanks for that man
pay it forward
be vigilant trouble never stays too far
away
Clementine you got your boyfriend you're
out of here too huh yeah
it's time I have to find AJ javi I've
waited so long but could you do me one
last favor before I leave what is it
I guess he has a favor
[Music]
I used to do this for my niece that's
nice of you
she thought I was terrible at it who are
you your business I'm really gonna miss
Gabe
I mean he's super annoying sometimes but
I've gotten used to having him around
yeah he's definitely at least to have
someone to talk to you not that he said
anything to me in particular but you
know the guys got a mondo crush on you
right
he does not oh my gosh you have a crush
on him too
I do not well you both have my blessing
I'm gonna stab you with those scissors
can we sell fine vaccine ow why do I see
AJ javi I have to see that he's okay do
you think he remembers me at least a
little
who could forget you Clint no one who
knew you I guaranteed yeah
maybe everyone told us he was better off
after everything that's happened I'm
starting to think they're right I don't
know if I was a good mom or not I can't
stop thinking about it did you open all
of my heart and of course you were
he told me you used to play baseball I
did I loved it
he told me you [ __ ] it all up to that
second batch yep sure did well you
survived I have to but you loved it
how do you survive that how if you
really loved it how you get back out
there and find something better there
may not be something better out there
you won't know until you step outside
all done
well how does it look
I've been again very different you know
what Oh grab your hat I remember this
team did that ever teach about baseball
no not really mine you come back I'll
tell you all about it it's a deal
if I bring AJ back with me
well you teach him too
abso-fuckin'-lutely you bet he belongs
with you Clementine bring him back
the whole gear we're looking at that
symbol to see if it like is intended an
ass and all the stuff together just
solder with the diagram cool jacket
okay now going to make so many babies
thank you thanks for everything
[Music]
all right that's the end your experience
at David was adversarial you're fused
his hand after you punched he punched
you on my father he tried to leave
Richmond without David there's how many
to distance himself from it
Gabe had to brain his own father after
David can get Kevin make signal how was
it mixed signal I guess I didn't kiss
her right here the leaves supported case
plan told them what a creature with a
focus in favor
[Music]
detach you upset him that's a trailer
you hid the truth about it's a brick
friend you know cubic foot replica so
strip died element alive
[Music]
a lot of you a [ __ ] die oh Jesus oh
[Music]
yeah you'll never died oh yeah we
confessed it
oh yeah baby I love Co shows I love that
won't Kate now I feel like a WoW a bow
thinker very cool okay well anyone say
it's a creditor
[Music]
so it's only been like two years old
AJ would be still like [ __ ] water -
maybe very how many [ __ ] posters I
got when I was like nine Jimmy Jean
welcomes any out goodness
alright thanks for watching y'all I hope
you all enjoyed it was really good I
think we did not take the path well
travel we took it less traveled and wait
I get it was interesting so thanks for
watching it back out